intuition comes from asking yourself
questions basic questions simple
questions just as it would Getting to
Know Rich getting to know Jay is the
same process after I eat something did I
like that did I not like it the next
morning did I like that did I not like
it when you ask people what are your
favorite movies you know how you feel
when you walk outside a movie no you
don't need to do a personality test you
don't need to do a a a 3 months away in
Costa Rica you don't need to do that to
know where whether you like something or
you don't like something you can do a
sense check with yourself every single
day after doing an activity and if you
literally after you did anything
anything you do stop and just ask
yourself did I enjoy that yes or no
simple question so let's say I say yes
what did you enjoy about it let's have
that conversation what did I enjoy about
it what part of it was uncomfortable but
you still got excited about it these are
three simple questions that can lead you
to Greater self-awareness